que pour répondre à ce que disait
guyonne très justement pourquoi c'est
plus possible de rassembler la droite
c'est parce que effectivement les
constructif
ils prennent acte de quoi de
l'approfondissement depuis 2005 disent
on va dire en gros depuis le rejet du
traité constitutionnel européen des
clivages culturels a simplement
sociétaux on résume souvent on assume ce
moment au sociétal la pma mais c'est
souvent les vrais clivages culturels
c'est la paix des vrais clip est là l
europe
les vrais clivages culturels
effectivement c'est l'articulation de
l'état nation l'état stratège comme
business florian philippot et de l'union
européenne
si on est un tant soit peu fédéral il
revient on ne peut pas regarder même si
on les individus ne sont pas en cause
mais on ne peut pas regardée avec
sympathie c'est mon cas la démarche de
laurent wauquiez pourquoi parce que la
démarche de laurent wauquiez
je la comprends parfaitement sais ce que
c'est de la triangulation politique mais
ça va se faire sur le dos de l'europe
hier qu'il va charger le baudet de
l'europe en dix ans évidemment ça c'est
la faute des mondialistes c'est la faute
des immigrationniste etc il va peut-être
ramener des électeurs du front national
le problème n'est pas là il va en
revanche faire basculer la droite du
côté du souverainisme le plus
réactionnaire et le plus rance
donc moi j'ai pas terrible souveraine
israir ans et réactionnaire pam agence
moi je vous donne de la voix n'était pas
oui ils étaient parés à jouer je vous
donne je vous donne mon interprétation
de l'actionnaire c'est pas mal je crains
qu'il y ait assez je crains tu dire que
l'on met que le souverainiste serait
rance où je crains qu'il y ait un
approfondissement des fractures titurel
denis ah ouais c'est mon seul souhait
est donc pour répondre à guillaume et si
tous les gars du monde pouvait se donner
la main ça serait formidable mais
aujourd'hui à droite ce n'est pas
possible car il ya des visions de la
société mais aussi de l'articulation de
la nation en europe
ils sont de plus en plus en tout cas j
zay